was war das beste hotel in dem ihr
jemals schlafen durfte bei mir ganz klar
das brenner's park inn dass sich auch
hier auf youtube getestet habe naja bis
letzte woche zumindest durch zufall bin
ich einem hotel gelandet dass alle meine
erwartungen völlig übertroffen hat und
einfach unheimlich gut war was ist so
besonders macht wie viel es kostet und
warum ich glaube dass das das beste
hotel mallorcas ist erfahrt ihr in
diesem video ich wünsche euch viel spaß
[Musik]
und bevor wir euch irgendwas vom hotel
oder vom zimmer zeiten natürlich
ausgiebig frühstücken denn so starten
vernünftig in meinem tag
[Musik]
das frühstück noch wasser offen
vielleicht wird es daher etwas abhilfe
geben
hier vorne gibt es frühstück und das
nicht zu knapp der opulent
für mich einen orangensaft einmal expect
für einen cappuccino mit
[Musik]
leicht wie er
und so schnell sind wir wieder beim
zimmer ohne laufen zum südpol gut weil
wir machen hier so viel so viel
körperliche aktivität dass wir uns das
auch noch sparen können und jetzt
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur natur
das beste umfeld zu machen indem ich
weis machen sonst im eingangsbereich
hier ist nicht nur der eingangsbereich
und menge ablagefläche für diverse
sachen die wir mit dem urlaub gebracht
haben sondern natürlich auch der stand
direkt daneben befindet sich eine kleine
küche eigentlich ist nur eine minibar
die super gefüllt ist mit diversen
sachen die wir dann aber noch weiter
gefüllt haben mit eigenen mitteln das
teure pillen nicht zahlen müssen direkt
daneben ein offenes fahren zimmer bei
dem max und ich uns gegenseitig
bestaunen können
eine große begehbare dusche boden tief
und allgemein muss ich sagen das ganze
hotel ist unheimlich stilvoll
eingerichtet farben passen alle super
gut zusammen es ist ein sehr
traditionsreiches haus beziehungsweise
gelände auf dem das hotel hier steht und
das würde unheimlich modernisiert ich
finde das hotel einfach unfassbar schön
tische hier doppeltes
waschbecken eine kleine toilette
habe ich eingesehen ja endlich an
bedient damit werde ich mir den arsch
einigen vom offenen eingangsbereich und
badezimmer geht es weiter in den
unheimlich großen orten wohnen und
schlafen
wir sind nämlich nicht im normalen
kleinen zu machen sondern wir haben
unsere gelten und das angebot von und
eine junior suite gebucht insgesamt
kostet dieses hotel
wird es am ende erfahren denn ihr könnt
mit grad ein kingsize unwahrscheinlicher
kingsize-bett zwei mal zwei meter max
und ich haben genug platz
ineinander gekuschelt schlafen zu müssen
wir tun sich klüpfel und direkt vor dem
bett was übrigens sehr bequem ist und wo
sie jeden tag an auf dexter es gibt also
nachdem man beim ersten mal kommt man
wieder und die decke ist umgeklappt
damit man noch ein leichter ins bett und
damit ins schlafgemach treten kann
befindet sich der arbeitsbereich mit
jeder menge staub fläche die wir
natürlich nicht brauchen coole moderne
steuerung von licht und des indirektes
licht oder deckenhöhe man fühlt sich
wirklich
weil es nicht super bowl und hatten am
ende passte man jedes zeugnis montag in
den wohnbereich hier kann man am sitzen
und wenn es draußen zu kalt werden
sollte was jetzt im sommer nicht der
fall ist könnte man hier entspannt
sitzen warum ich aber glaube dass das
hotel auch unheimlich gut im winter oder
im herbst funktioniert wenn es auch auf
malle nicht mehr so super bahn ist dazu
komme ich später dass sich aber toll
finde auf die integration der
klimaanlage richtig gut zum einen sehr
nachhaltig funktioniert die klimaanlage
nur wenn alle fenster geschlossen sind
und somit automatisch außer dem was
geöffnet ist und dann befindet sich der
gesamte klima outlet hier in dieser
branche hängt also nicht mal irgendwas
an der wand oder so halt darum dass sie
etwas laut ist würde ich sagen und sich
anhört wie als würde ein pool und
bekanntlich wir haben die nächte echt
super gut geschlafen und das zimmer
konnte die perfekt in der natur halten
also auch hier wieder einfach unheimlich
hohe qualität gehen raus zu unserem
eigenen terrassenbereich das wertet die
grill hören denn wir befinden uns mitten
in der natur das hier ist
unser breit wo wir eine eigene liga
haben eigene sitze und hier haben wir in
den letzen kann die arbeit verweigert
hier haben wir auch ein stück der 350
hektar wie zum hotel gehören hier sind
freilaufende ziegen gekommen auch dann
mal hier vorbei und wie kriegt man auf
dem bild wenn man zum essen geht also
man fühlt sich als wäre dieses hotels
mitten in die natur wir haben einen
fernseher mit dem wir auch benutzt haben
mit den ganzen kabel wieder mit
übertragen so denn wir wollen natürlich
auch unsere serien und alles was wir zu
hause so angefangen haben hier urlaub
weiter schauen und das ganze
funktioniert natürlich mit der hilfe von
jpm wir haben weiterhin zugriff auf alle
unsere lieblings inhalte und können
sogar auf inhalte zugreifen die gar
nicht in unserem land verfügbar sind mit
nur einem klick kann man nämlich seinen
virtuellen standort zwischen über 5000
der besten vpn server weltweit wechseln
dadurch bekommen wir außerdem die
möglichkeit streaming plattform zu einem
günstigeren preis zu buchen ist das
streaming aber unserer wahl also in
einem anderen land günstiger wechseln
wir unseren virtuellen standort in
buchen das abo und bezahlen dauerhaft
weniger aber auch abseits von streaming
ist not op en unheimlich wichtig um
dauerhaft sichere surfen zu garantieren
jpm stellt sich nämlich vor schädlicher
software und malware und dank nord links
müsst ihr euch auch keine sorgen um eure
bandbreite macht so könnt ihr einfach
bei gleichbleibender geschwindigkeit
deutlich sicherer surfen und das prüfen
von videos vermeiden und das ganze mit
eben nur einem klick das ganze jetzt
über den ersten in der video
beschreibung aus über
www.fem.com schlecht denn vpn findet ihr
nämlich einen exklusiven deal den ihr
komplett risikofrei testen können 30
tage geld zurück garantie ist das
nämlich super stressfall möglich und ich
bedanke mich vielmals bei nordhoff
werden für eine weitere unterstützung
dieses videos und euch viel spaß weiter
mit der hut und aufgrund dieser
unheimlichen anstrengungen des
vorangegangen den drehs von gerade und
des weitergeführten arbeiten hier
draußen am max und ich uns entschlossen
unsere kleine abkühlung zu können und
wir schauen mal ob es möglich ist diese
abkühlung durch die rezeption
unterstützen zu lassen und einfach es
hierhin zu bestellen einfach so um zu
sehen ob es funktioniert
wenn das tier das damit henrichs calling
von number five hundred im team
monika fitz possible to get some nice to
do
denke
ja es ist so geil und es fühlt sich so
falsch
das fühlt sich trotz alledem irgendwie
so ein bisschen falsch und dass hier
weniger sein dass hier schon aber dafür
bin ich
ja also tatsächlich ist ja so dass ich
sonst nur in hotels geschlafen habe um
youtube-videos darüber zu drehen und
mein leben lang urlaub auf dem
campingplatz gemacht habt mit meinen
eltern das jetzt das erste mal dass ich
privaten im hotel bin und ich muss schon
sagen ich kann verstehen warum leuten
das so gut gefällt
mir jetzt bitte so fürstliche musik
dienstes sid
[Musik]
naja kann meine heimat
das hotelzimmer ist ja schon ziemlich
dunkel aber bei weitem nicht das beste
hotel und was dazu führt dass ich glaube
dass das das beste hotel ist in dem ich
jemals war und vielleicht sogar das
beste hotel mallorcas ist das schauen
uns jetzt gemeinsam an
[Musik]
das hier sind alles alte gebäude die
ohren gebaut wurden renoviert wurden wie
auch immer und an welche daneben neue
häuser anbauten angebaut wurden wie zum
beispiel hier vorne der
frühstücksbereich und ich finde das
unheimlich gut gelungen also wirklich
sehr sehr viel wollten
hier kommen wir in den innenhof des
eigentlichen hauptgebäudes sich ganz
viele zimmer und jetzt unserer linken
befindet sich die bahn das ist nicht das
einzige lokal in dem man unterkommen
kann per ecke rechts wo wir gefrühstückt
haben gibt es nämlich restaurant nummer
eins und auf der seite des spa und
poolbereich wo jetzt hingehen
ein bisschen mehr werden einige
unheimlich gut und damit ihr seht wie
gut die qualität ist
[Musik]
und das hier platz in einem der beiden
restaurants von hier man kein ausblick
aufs meer das hotel bzw die gesamte
anlage ist nämlich nicht direkt am meer
sondern auf einer erhöhung mitten im
niemandsland quasi aber man hat
zumindest wunderbaren blick auf port
alcúdia
wunderbar
diese portion pasta kostet jetzt sowas
wie 15 euro 18 euro das ist natürlich
unheimlich viel aber im urlaub denke ich
gerade in so einem setting und so kann
man sich das können wenn man dann lust
darauf hat man an dieser stelle und wird
jetzt beides gleich mal probieren und
euch sagen was er davon hält
das findet mit chris kurbelten schwarzen
truppe ist der preis nicht her es ist ja
keine einfache gruppe passen sondern
eine weiße karriere
seinen und rückwärts chimp ist sehr
lecker und werde mich dazu wissen wir
haben gestern schon hier gegessen und
nicht mal etwas enttäuscht ich habe mir
einen burger bestellt für 22 euro und
was mich erwartet aber einen fertigen
partie grundsätzlich jetzt kein
riesenproblem aber wenn man so unendlich
viel geld für eine hauptspeise ausgibt
dann hätte man wahrscheinlich schon ein
bisschen was anderes erwartet aber dass
hier scheint er jetzt auf einem
angemessenen level zu lange man kann
sich sehr gut gelaufen
[Musik]
das ist wahr das ist der pool und das
ist max ein absolutes fest für
gewöhnlich kann ich euch den spar
bereichen die vernünftig zeigen weil er
natürlich immer belegt ist und hier
jetzt im besten hotel spa in dem ich
jemals war ist gerade niemand und ich
kann nicht alles zeigen
[Musik]
ob wir starten in der mitte des raumes
hier unendlich viele entspannungsbereich
noch deutlich mehr entspannungsbereich
wieder sehr stilvoll diese aussicht ein
wunderbarer garten also das muss man
wirklich sagen auch die ganzen
gartenanlagen sind hier super gut
gemacht und dazu eben eine terrasse bei
der man dann im spa bereich auch noch
draußen die sonne genießen kann und
dieser bereich ist der grund warum ich
glaube dass dieses hotel auch super gut
im herbst und im winter funktioniert
weil es einfach mega viel angebot gibt
na ja auch in etwas kälteren tagen eine
gute zeit zu verbringen eine feuerstelle
bußgelder und werner amon diverse
getränke
etwas eis diverse duschen und hier sauna
dampfbad sauna und einfach toll ist es
riesengroß direkt über uns also genau da
befindet sich der autor tun aber das ist
ja nicht natürlich nicht der einzige
freude haben denn im spa bereich gibt es
auch noch ein indoor pool
[Musik]
ach du scheiße also guckt euch das mal
an wir haben den ausblick nach draußen
in einem perfekt gemachten garten dies
ist so ein bisschen so schattenspiel
einen riesigen indoor-pool ich glaube
der ist länger als draußen und ich finde
es sieht in jedem winkel einfach
unheimlich gut aus also wirklich das ist
richtig krass was soll ich sagen
unheimlich gut ich finde dass dieser spa
und poolbereich das ganze nochmal
komplett unterstreicht wie hochwertig
das ganze hier um und aufgebaut wurde
wirklich unheimlich gutes angebot das
team kommt es leider nicht zeigen da
waren gerade andere gestern trainieren
aber das ist futsch neue technogym
geräten es macht keinen unterschied
liche würde es natürlich niemals
benutzen im urlaub und auch sonst nicht
aber es wäre da
[Musik]
und genau das was ich hier gerade im
hintergrund ist vermutlich das was es
für mich zum schönsten hotel macht in
dem ich jemals war so ein lauer
sommerabend absolute ruhe gar nicht
zugebaut hier wirklich ein riesen weiter
blick wenn man will auf die piste und
einfach pure entspannung
[Musik]
jetzt aber zur bewertung des karussells
bei hotels auf mallorca das zimmer
sauber stilvoll eingerichtet eigene
terrasse und supermodern aber wir waren
eben auf einem berg mit unglaublich gute
aussicht auf verschiedene buchten und
davon hätten wir vielleicht auch gerne
was im zimmer gesehen deswegen halber
punkt abzug 4,5 von 5 sternen deshalb
ist supergut besondere wünsche wie eis
und so waren überhaupt kein problem man
konnte sich komplett rum fahren lassen
wenn man keine lust hatte zu laufen und
alle waren super freundlich und weil es
ein privat urteil ist also keine kette
hatte man wirklich das gefühl dass
irgendwie so ein bisschen familiärer ist
viel weniger so etepetete wie so ein
brenner's park inn oder in four seasons
und natürlich wir waren auf malle 17 das
bundesland von deutschland der komplette
service alle bestellungen alles war
komplett auf deutsch möglich also
kompletter service fast alle
angestellten konnten fließend deutsch
ziemlich cool und von fünf sternen
verpflegung unheimlich gutes und
ausgiebiges frühstück und in den
restaurants stabiles essen das max aber
jetzt nicht wirklich aus den socken
gehauen hat ein ort weiter bei einem
restaurant dass es partie heißt haben
wir für gleiches geld wirklich deutlich
besser gegessen und außerdem hat mich
dieser burger mit fertig petty für 22
euro so ein bisschen aus dem konzept
gebracht und das halte ich für ein
absolutes no-go in kombination mit den
doch schon gehobenen preisen für mich
eine 3 5 von 5 sternen es war gut aber
teuer und es hat eigentlich aus den
socken gehauen sauberkeit absolut top
jeden tag reinigung vom zimmer ziemlich
ausgiebig so gar keine probleme im
spa-bereich und besonders die
grünflächen beziehungsweise
gartenflächen draußen haben uns richtig
geflasht alles war perfekt gemacht ist
zwar unheimlich gut aus wenn wir uns
richtig wohlgefühlt und weil ich aber im
urlaub war und dieses video gar nicht
geplant hatte konnten wir diesmal den
schwarzlicht test nicht machen trotz
alledem bin ich mir absolut sicher dass
es nichts zu bemängeln gegeben hätte 5
und fünf sternen für die sauberkeit die
lage absolute 55 das sage ich euch jetzt
schon mal für alle leute die komplette
ruhe suchen weil das genau das war was
wir gesucht haben und weil wir uns genau
deswegen auch für dieses hotel
entschieden haben gibt es gar nichts zu
bemängeln wenn man dann mal lust auf
trubel hat 25 minuten nach cala ratjada
oder 35 minuten nach port alcúdia was
auch ziemlich schönes aber wir wollten
die ruhe wir haben die ruhe bekommen das
hotel mitten im nirgendwo genau was wir
wollten 5 von 5 perfekt preis etwas
schwierig wir sind in absoluten
hochsaison gefahren die nrw sommerferien
ging gerade los und wir haben am abend
unserer ankunft dieses hotel gebucht und
wir haben 418 euro für die junior suite
inklusive frühstück bezahlt also
ungefähr 200 euro pro person pro nacht
was natürlich komplett krank ist ich
hatte dann auch noch mal nachgeschaut
für ein standardzimmer was auch 30
quadratmeter groß ist bezahlt man in so
leichter oft saison also anfang
september muss aber immer noch warm ist
300 euro für zwei personen ein zimmer
inklusive frühstück und abendessen für
dieses geld kann man sich überhaupt
nicht beschweren wenn ihr euch mal so
ein luxushotel gönnen wollte dann
bekommt ihr dort viel mehr meiner
meinung nach als im brenners oder im
four seasons was die beiden anderen
luxushotels waren die ich bisher auf
youtube getestet haben also das wirklich
absolute empfehlung für 400 euro ohne
abendessen würde ich vermutlich nicht
wieder machen und ein standardzimmer
reicht allemal also weniger dumm gebucht
als wir und mit sicht auf die allgemeine
preisstruktur des hotels ist für mich
eine 455 das ist die gesamtbewertung des
hotels es hat mir unheimlich gut
gefallen vielen dank an neue vpn falls
euch das video auch gefallen hat lassen
wir werden dann liegt da vergesse ich
den kanal zu abonnieren ich bin jetzt
quasi aus der sommerpause wieder da und
jetzt wird wieder angegriffen couscous
macht's gut ciao ciao macht es gut ich
laufe mit dem ton davon